good evening
and made
publicly through the state house website
this is not a typical medium that helps
our senate committees
not all committee members are here
we will be starting it before we do i
ask that you join me
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
as you all of you know but people
watching me not this meeting is
occurring at the stratfor
courthouse of the superior court system
for county
and the scrappers county commissioners
please understand that while we are in
this facility neither the courts of new
hampshire or the county commissioners of
stratfor
have had anything to do with this public
input session
or the redistricting process that is as
it is underway the general court the
house of representatives in the senate
staff of the general board has worked to
secure places to hold these sessions in
each housing throughout the state and
i'm grateful to the staff and
organizations that control the use of
this facility for allowing us to be here
tonight
tonight we have members of the house and
the senate with us
um i believe that senator gray
who convenes the senate beauty minus
matter i am yes all right um
[Music]
i
district seven which i'm sorry district
90 which encompasses the towns of
derry hampstead
as senator
and i am james gray i represent district
six which starts in rochester 11.
uh
one thing that i want to mention is
there are two committee meetings going
on simultaneously
um it is not permitted to
fight or vote okay
that's a deformed we want to make sure
that's maintained
and we did have
one incident over the last one to get
that
so you will be gathering with you know
your favorite classroom
so just so you know
thank you
um
my name is barbara griffin i'm a
representative from boston
good evening everyone i'm representing
glenn turner
district 4 which is the town of
barrington i served on the finance
committee
redistricting committee and senior
advisor from the house
and the website
[Music]
about how they would like to see the
district livestrong
chairman
from walpole also represented
[Music]
is
thank you
[Music]
issues starting on this committee i
serve on the house election
i'm connie lane i represent war ii in
concord i am also on the election law
committee
[Music]
process i see some cases that were here
at the hearing last week in air math but
i did wanted to take this opportunity to
go through it again
information on the redistricting process
for the house of representatives can be
found on the general court website once
there select the house of
representatives then select committees
and select standing committees there's
also information on the senate page i
speak to the house
this is a process you use to speak to
any committee and one of the standing
committees is this special committee on
redistricting
and also has a website for the committee
that page has additional information on
it for this special committee on
redistricting one of the things you will
find on that page among other things is
a link for meeting minutes and
recordings and that's where the videos
for this
meeting
itself is a process that occurs
throughout the country every ten years
after the federal census completed the
population data
for representation at all levels of
government here in new hampshire our
constitution says that the
responsibility for the creation of those
districts is that of the legislature
will be the congressional
the executive council the state senate
the state representative there is also
redistricting for county commissioner
districts and delegates to the state
department bench
um there were handouts on the outside
table for you um
if there were not enough hopefully
you can share we had a few more than
last week but i think we might have a
few more people than have last week
so please pick those up if you haven't
and they're available
and it will be helpful for you on the
house side i will tell you to comment on
things that you think are important for
redistricting in your accounting
stratfor county um but you can obviously
make comments on other districts also
there were sign up sheets by the first
one
we're gonna ask people who are speaking
to come up to
to make sure when we put this online
that people can see and hear what is
going on um there are a number of people
signed up and i see other people signing
up so they help with a flow of comments
tonight representative tur park who's a
representative from here from stratford
will be um calling you up to come and
address the committee with your comments
and again when he asks you to come
forward if you come to this chair that
would be terrific i'm going to ask you
to identify yourself too because again
that will help people who are watching
the video understand what is going on
tonight thank you
representative
thank you madam
chair there's one
up on the list of susan richmond
please come forward
[Music]
the
well
disclosure we have to see this
but input as long as there is not
accessed by a doom i know maybe
has not been able to participate because
he is mentally
comparable by
ensure effective representation well i
feel sorry for the matter is overwhelmed
by durham but in terms of the senatorial
district
durham used to have a separate senate
and now uh
rebecca is doing a wonderful table job
but her district is not compact and she
has two very large
democratic
democratic sisters
and durham and so i believe that that is
an example of partisan packing
and that there
is not real effective representation
of
democrats in new hampshire when we're
all put into one
also
this district
that we have now 21 senate district 21
crosses county lines portsmouth new
fields are in rockingham county
durham madbury we're in stratford county
and and there are other towns as well
but
but we cross county lines and also
as of um since
2011 barrington has joined the oyster
river school district so now effectively
the
senate
legislative representatives
these their listening principles would
be sacred
maps so my final time please hold
hearings for us to view the maps once
they have been designed
thank you
[Music]
okay next on the list we have su nastasi
hi i'm sunastasi of rollinsford
i have a dover mailing address but i
live and pay taxes in rollinsford
the town votes for four state
representatives
our current representatives consists of
one living excuse me for a minute could
you pull that mic a little bit closer to
you oh sure
a little more
oh
thank you
should i start over or i'll just keep
going
oh
[Music]
okay sue continue well that's fine okay
thank you
okay our current representatives consist
of one living in rollinsford and three
in somersworth
hold on one
second let's wait another minute
we're hearing with the setup
okay okay
our town 2020 census showed us at a
population of 2597.
i know you will have to combine this
with dover or somersworth but these
cities are so much larger it drowns out
the voices
of romesford voters
i am pleased and proud to be one of the
three supervisors of the checklist
serving the town and keeping our voting
records exact and up to date has been
meaningful
my town is situated on the western bank
of the salmon falls river which divides
new hampshire
and maine
it's approximately 14 miles from the
atlantic ocean
and our neighboring cities are dover and
somersworth new hampshire and south
berwick maine
and i want to thank you chairperson
griffin for allowing me to speak before
the redistricting committee
i hope i will have time after the maps
are drawn to add my voice to the debate
i wanted to say
accurate representation equals fair maps
being accurate is for the voters to
choose their representatives
not
for any political candidate to decide
their constituents
also being accurate is doing the job
elected to do
and following the constitution
when representatives are drawing maps to
pac districts they are not doing their
job packing i'm sure you know but the
act of grouping together members of one
group within a district to the point
that they are a super majority in that
district
this reduces the electoral influence of
the group in the surrounding districts
executive council district 2 is an
example of packing
and
we would appreciate if that could be
reviewed more closely on the next
drawing of the bats
your work is appreciated by all in the
state so much work is done on your own
time
the committee and covet guidelines have
caused increased demands of time
travel and plain rearrange in your life
please give all voters the confidence
that this redistricting committee will
do the right thing
and i wanted to say also that the
following uh warned article
uh
was passed on june 8th
during the town meeting in rollinsford
by a vote of 406 to 105 the resolution
for fair redistricting
so but thank you so much for your time
thank you for your work
thank you
next on the list uh madeline desantis
waissaki
how'd i do
all right
it's okay it's my husband's name
um good evening senators representatives
um thank you for visiting us in
stratford county
um thank you for letting us address you
tonight my name is madeline desantis
wysocki i've lived in somersworth for 25
years and i'm here to encourage you to
both draw fair maps and to come and
visit us again after you have drawn said
maps
i recently learned that 10 years after
the last redistricting process the
public only had 24 hours to react to new
maps um and while i appreciate your
presence here tonight there is nothing
yet for the public to review or critique
except last year or last
cycles maps which we know um includes
more than one gerrymander
to really have a robust dialogue with
the public and one that creates the most
fair outcome i strongly encourage you to
return to these communities that you're
visiting after the maps have been drawn
for review
in summersworth specifically this is
important because our ward lines are
likely to be redrawn shortly after your
maps are drawn
um
for example in somersworth ward 3 and
ward
5 i think there's a 500 person
difference so
that will probably be adjusted in the
coming years
um
uh in particular also the executive
council as has been mentioned uh
district 2 is the greatest example of a
pac gerrymander
there are decisions happening at the
executive council level that directly
impact my life but my voice has been
deluded because the last redistricting
packed democrats into one district uh
that isn't just bad for one party or
another uh it hurts residents
somersworth has the same executive
counselor as westmoreland which is over
100 miles away and bordering vermont
while somersworth borders maine
as i mentioned i've lived in
summersworth for nearly 25 years i was
married in 2017. we bought a house in
2019 and soon we'll start a family i'm
not the only one somersworth is
experiencing a boom in young families
the next 10 years are going to be
pivotal for my life and so many other
young families and summers within our
surrounding communities i encourage this
committee to keep that in mind draw fair
maps and come back after those maps are
drawn and allow for public feedback
thank you
thank you for your testimony
next up
nate stewart from dover
[Music]
good evening to the chair and uh
committee members my name is uh nate
stewart i live in dover new hampshire
and i've lived there since 1998. so i
was around
2010 during the last one of these i
wasn't at one of these meetings though
because i was very young
and i think that's something i'd like to
touch on a bit in my remarks here
is that i'd like to know uh
what potentially is being done to
include the youth of the state in
uh these sorts of considerations uh we
have a big issue with youth flight uh
from new hampshire a lot of our best and
brightest go elsewhere and i think a lot
of that is because a lot of people a are
being priced out of the state but b
don't feel like their government
represents them and doesn't feel like
they can have a voice so
uh
i would like to echo some of the
concerns about transparency
accessibility
and uh the lack of having things to
really remark upon at these meetings
because we don't have a map so how can
we
give our full like comments on the
process at this stage
like i can say like please respect the
communities
please respect the
natural
sort of
groupings that there are the school
districts and whatnot but until there's
a map that we can consider
like
i don't know what good that's going to
do and i don't know how specific my
remarks can be so i'd like to strongly
encourage these committees to come back
once you have a map and i'd very much
like to comment on it
another thing that i would like to say
is
please make sure that you respect
majority rule
and please make sure that the districts
that you develop
are reflective of uh
the
true
number of people there like if you have
one district which is like
wildly uh
partisan surrounded by a bunch of other
districts that are wildly partisan
you're not going to get an accurate
representation of the area it's better
to have
neutral districts or districts again
that like
um
[Music]
are
reflective of how things are and not
gerrymandered uh i feel like there's
been a general
uh
decay in trust in government and trust
in
uh
[Music]
democracy and i feel like if majority
rule is undermined through
[Music]
districting maneuvers
that would only further that decline and
ultimately cause terminal harm to our
very republic i think you know most
people my generation most people in the
country at large aren't blind to the
fact that we just had uh not
a year ago an attempted coup in
washington and that sort of uh drastic
uh effect
comes from years of
uh systemic
partisan
attacks on the very root of our
democracy
i don't trust the government i don't
think uh many people trust the
government which is why we need
transparency and
[Music]
a real input instead of just being given
a microphone at a meeting that isn't
well advertised and is kind of out a
little bit in the middle of nowhere uh
that a lot of people
you know can't access
uh the meeting's being recorded and i
know that the chair said that
uh it couldn't be on zoom because that's
the
ruling of the uh chair of the general
court right uh
but like
it seems to me
that
[Music]
we can't pass
the buck like
we need to recognize where deficiencies
are we need to recognize
where
uh
issues lay
and um
i feel like accessibility is a big one
uh
yeah i guess that's about it i'll yield
my time i'll yield my time
thank you
for your input nate next up i'm sorry i
cannot read the first name last name is
freeman i don't know if it's aina ivy
ian
my name is ivor freeman
i live in exeter
and i've come to ask you each of you
to look in the mirror every day
and ask the question
am i for democracy or am i for bias
because that is the really important
question for the population of this
state
and when you've decided that question
for transparency purposes you should
publicize it publicize it
it is really important that the people
know
what you stand for individually
and in transparency
you have to be
really clear
in what you stand for
and please
vote for democracy and not for bias
thank you
next is maggie fogarty
hello good evening my name is maggie
fogerty i live
at 16 florence street in dover where my
husband and i have owned a home for
about 23 and a half years
and as a first-time candidate for public
office i'm running for school board in
ward 1 in dover so i'm getting to know
my ward
and all of the little streets so the
most important message that i want to
convey this evening is that the
committee
to echo others who have gone before me
uh must release the draft maps so that
the public can see them can give input
to them so that the process is
transparently uh demonstrating the kinds
of decisions that you're making and the
logic behind them
and why one alternative
map line would be chosen over another
i want to echo others who have lifted up
the
bizarrely drawn executive council
district 2
of which dover is a part
a district that where democrats are
packed giving republicans a better
chance to win the other four districts
it seems clear that the design of this
district
is intended to distort the
representation and to favor a political
agenda that is being revealed as
increasingly anti-democratic
uh another example to lift up is that
dover awards five and six both have
populations significant enough to merit
their own seat in the new hampshire
house of representatives
um as according to the numbers uh
defined in the new hampshire
constitution
but instead these wards share
three representatives with a somersworth
district 2
which is less coherent and is also
unfair
to the residents of somersworth ward 2
because
as a smaller share of the whole it is
harder for a summers worth person to be
elected in a district dominated by dover
voters
i agree with the messages that that
everything is at stake with how we enact
these processes the integrity of our
democracy so i urge you to
to be conscientiously transparent and
accountable and to allow us to see the
draft maps with an opportunity for
meaningful feedback thank you very much
thank
you representative
thank you um
madam chair my question to the witness
is that as i review the um size of each
of the
somersworth
wards i see that not one of them is
large enough
to warrant its own
representative
and therefore
they have to be combined in some way
um with someone else and i so
i see that as a problem that we have to
face just as i see the problem that we
have to face
that i do not believe that the city of
dover
has
yet completed steps necessary
to equalize the population in wards
given that and
what would the
witness expect this committee to do to
be able to solve these problems
[Music]
thank you representative smith for you
for your question i i the intent of this
meeting is to hear from you and i i ask
for the question to be addressed to me
because i don't want anybody put on the
spot in regards to any sort of questions
or information requests um the
information regarding all of this is
available online and just to clarify
when we draw house district lines and
that i'm assuming is the district that
you're talking about in regards to your
own representative and i'm saying this
as an informational piece um we have to
stay within county lines
um
town and city lines and ward lines
so when a city has wards and many of the
cities throughout the state will are
not on the same timeline that we are
um when the wards are there they need to
be combined with something so i want to
thank the witness for her testimony in
regards to
the city
but would just point out generally to
everybody who might be testifying on
cities that wards are a consideration
for this committee in regards to
district boundaries thank you may i
speak with just one sentence to what's
been raised as i depart my chair
just that i'm coming to understand this
process myself
and was not engaged in any detail uh ten
years ago but i am aware that through i
think it's the open democracy mapathon
project that there are ways of designing
maps that take into account the
complexities that you describe i just
to
ask for as much transparency and
accountability in the in the next phases
of the process as possible thank you
thank you i think one item that the uh
chairs oh no
this is for everybody one item that the
chair brought up at the very beginning
tonight is the website uh if you go to
the website that uh
chair griffin described earlier you're
gonna find more information than you've
ever wanted to know on redistricting uh
it's it's worth a look and uh
you'll learn a lot by going there
uh next up we have polana hunt hawkins
[Music]
right
uh hi my name is lana hunt hawkins thank
you all for being here and coming to our
county today and for uh working to
hopefully draw some fair maps uh i live
on old dover road in rochester i wear a
number of hats i'm currently a city
councilor i'm running for mayor of
rochester um
i have no major complaints about
currently how our house districts go we
have six wards there's nine seats three
floaters um
that work out to two wards each i think
that we're very fortunate that it's so
neat um and that we're not you know
sharing um representation with other
potentially unlike uh
towns
um when it comes to our senate district
in our executive council district though
um i think people are going to keep
bringing up executive council district 2
is something where the shape just
doesn't make any sense and i think that
the state acknowledges it and that the
travel stipend is higher for that
district than in any other one
similarly with our senate district um
it's rochester and then most of the
areas north of it i think that we're
kind of grouped in with mostly unlike uh
towns and remote towns there are no
cities north of us that are part of the
district um so i i think that should be
something that's considered in this next
round of redistricting definitely
looking at the executive council
district two um and i really hope that
we have an opportunity more than the 24
hours that was allotted last time to
give feedback once there have been um
once lines have been drawn
um and that's it thank you all
thank you for your testimony jerry
cannon
thank you madam chair and
auguste
fella fellow legislator members and you
have an awesome task ahead of you
my name is representative jerry cannon i
represent stratfor county 18
which is covers
wards 1 3 4 and 5 in somersworth and the
small town of rollinsburg
i sit on the health and human services
and elderly affairs committee
as well as somersworth school board
where i'm running for my third term
the big concerns that we have in the
city of somersworth
that i've seen is that challenge our
elderly and new
people who are recently involved with
our legislative voting process
and trying to understand who
is running
and who is running
in their ward
it's
very difficult when for instance this
year
all of the people that will be voting
for local office
are voting for people who all live in
the city of somersworth
but next year
as was mentioned previously the people
in ward 2 won't be voting for all of the
represent representatives that live in
the town of somersworth
they're going to have to vote
consider
representatives from dover as well as
the city of somersworth
i've been approached by numerous elderly
members who have
been very frustrated when they've gone
to the polls and find out they can't
vote
for the people they thought they were
going to vote that their friends were
talking about from other parts of the
city and they were all set to vote for
people and find out their names are not
on the ballot
i had one of the members of my church
actually she
had a fit
at the polling location and they had to
calm her down and said this is the way
it is
as a rep i'm frustrated
because i'm representing the city of
somersworth
in a small town of rosford where things
are quite different
luckily we do have a rep who lives in
rawensford and work closely with her
but if all the reps that were
elected from
into district 18 were from somersworth
they would be left out without a
representative living in their town
it's difficult for me also when a
resident from somersworth
who lives in ward 2
contacts me to ask them to represent
them in their issue in concord
i end up doing that anyways
i also have to refer them to the
legislators that are representing their
ward
but
i'm a representative of my community and
i will stand up for them
lastly i'm asking you to please plan to
hold
listening sessions
for the public to better understand
any changes you're making to the maps
that might impact them when they're
voting
and figuring out who's going to
represent them thank you
thank you representative
again i'll do my best on this one so
[Music]
comedy
there's someone it's she's from dover
sylmar
okay well we'll go on uh next uh david
hall
[Music]
hi
my name is david holt i am a lifelong
resident of new hampshire and a
homeowner of 20 years
in somersworth new hampshire i live at
7a ash street
uh thank you all for coming here and
listening to us i have a few points to
make um
we need to ensure that everyone has a
say in this registry uh covet is still
an issue and even if we're not there's
always going to be people who are going
to find it difficult to attend meetings
such as this in person
we need to have virtual accessibility so
that everyone has a voice
in the process
we need a say not just before the maps
are drawn but before they're finalized
as it's been said before
we really need to have a public hearing
to allow everyone to be able to weigh in
on
what the
tentative
decisions are on what the districts will
be
part of the reason for this is that we
have
gerrymandering that is
uh rampant across the country and across
the state
we should all want to ensure that our
legislators are beholden to their
constituents the severe gerrymandering
taking place in new hampshire and the
u.s is destroying our democracy
legislators act on their own or their
donors interests because they know with
the system in place they are unlikely to
lose future elections
but there are many issues and not
everyone in either party agrees on all
of them
even those who have gerrymandered to
ensure easy victories for the
legislators may find themselves subject
to legislative votes that affect them
detrimentally
one great example that's been brought up
many times tonight is the second
executive council
district
which stretches all the way from vermont
to maine
this is gerrymandered to the ninth
degree
we have a right to fair representation
and this is not it
uh we have little in common with people
that live about two hours away
somersworth and every town and city
should have their own representatives uh
we have no one who is speaking just for
somersworth i have no problems with our
representatives i uh
highly recommend all of them but we need
to have representatives for somersworth
with the numbers as they're stated
3444 per district we could have three
possibly four representatives in
somersworth uh someone had made the
point before that um
a single ward doesn't uh have enough
people to to be its own district but
at the same time i also wanted to point
out that these words are going to be
redrawn uh within the next few years and
they are not being redrawn by the same
body
so they will
totally disrupt whatever decisions you
folks make so one of the ways to
minimize the damage of that is to uh to
try to keep the uh the ward districts
within the the town and give every town
or city its own representatives
um
[Music]
one of the things that our new hampshire
state constitution requires that the
state legislative districts be
contiguous and preserve political
subdivisions
and that was brought up
uh
but to
give the same weight to wards that are
going to be redrawn
by a separate entity is
nonsensical
so
sorry
so basically i just want to emphasize
that we need to have a
fair democracy here and what we are
getting with the gerrymandering is not
that so again thank you very much for
showing up and i hope that you will take
my uh
thoughts into consideration and i'll
just leave some of my notes here
[Music]
thank you mr holt
next up we have matt town
good evening representatives thanks for
coming and give us an opportunity to
speak today
i really have kind of a progression of
points i wish to make
and it starts out with the notion that
many of the speakers before me have
spoken to and there's the issue of
fairness and transparency
this is gets painted about it gets
talked about
but there are a simple couple of tests
and i'll speak to those as i go through
but the simple test is can you explain
how you ended up with that final map
that that
test can you explain it with a straight
face
that's the test i would ask for you to
to internalize and to bring into that
process
so
new hampshire has a history of
gerrymandering it's been shown by
several studies of the
new hampshire political
reapportionment system
and unfortunately
with this history of gerrymandering when
we look at
the executive council structure from
border to border no one can look at that
with straight face and say that's
appropriate
and what does that do to our population
what does it do role of voters when we
have to go out there and ask them to
vote
so within my town we had difficulty
getting
our representatives to actually speak to
us about the last election the
difficulty with that is it really
undermines public trust
given our history of gerrymandering and
the redemption commission that was
vetoed by the governor not once but
twice
um you know that will undermines when
you can't say that to uh the voter and
expect them to have a uh understanding
why an independent commission was not
the way to go with this it's so deeply
partisan
that combined with the gop chair
guaranteed his constituents
that they would win the seat in
manchester and he directly alluded to
gerrymander as the reason he was so
confident the gop would capture the the
house seat and the congressional house
seat
what does that do to public confidence
in the last election in my town for a
select board not a huge statewide
position i'll give you that but only 13
percent of our population voted
think about that 13
so that tells me that people are just
like it doesn't matter what my vote is
you folks have an opportunity to take
the high road and make sure that this
thing is transparent and easily
communicated
[Music]
the consequences you know i spoke to
somewhat in terms of disconnect from the
the voters and when i uh i speak to
the uh the population i was a candidate
this last election
that there is deep distrust but also
deep you know it's a lack of knowledge
about the process we have an opportunity
i should say you have the opportunity
now to make sure that this is well
communicated and brought into our town
so my final point
with that would simply be
that when you get done with this
you should make it a standing policy
that this has to be brought before
uh a forum in each individual town so a
representative comes before the town and
shows the map and this is what we did
and this is why we did it but that has
to be in person in front of
uh the voters
the reason for that being in person is
that that makes it real
the difficulty of having this well it's
on the website
i'm sorry i spent a lot of time in the
computer these things are not as easily
obtained as you might think you live
inside that website you know where
you're going
and for many of our folks particularly
with the elderly and the harass to young
parents they're not going to go on their
website so if you don't come before the
voters person to person and make it real
it will not get
communicated so i strongly urge that you
hold yourself up as a rep in front of
your town
and and show some some courage in front
of the voters and explain why you did
what you did
thank you
thank you stan for your testimony
uh next we have jim versh neren
sharon
so my name is jim burscher and i live in
dover new hampshire at 102 b 6th
and
i'm here tonight as a former state
representative
and i just want to say i know that the
vast majority of us serve as elected
officials
because we care about our state
and what is best for its people i think
that our the extra mile each of you are
going for being on this committee is
commendable and i thank you for it
yours is a sacred trust
sacred to our democracy
sacred to each of us who believe in the
promise of america
i have watched the earlier listening
session you held in merrimack county
many there testified about the details
of the 2010 redistricting
and many exhorted you to operate in a
transparent manner
and work to create a fair set of
districts
i second those please there's no need
for me to repeat them here others have
already and will continue to do that i'm
sure
yours is a sacred trust
if we as a people are con
continue to believe in our democracy
we must have trust that our votes
our most fundamental right and
responsibility will count
when districts are created to manipulate
election results
we all lose
republicans in gerrymandered democratic
districts may as well not vote
the same for democrats and republican
districts
when state legislatures become lopsided
in favor of one party or the other
unrepresentative of the state
because districts have been drawn to
ensure partisan victories
we as a people lose our trust
many give up on participation
and our democracy is seriously eroded
and so i urge you
both democrats and republicans
to set aside your party affiliation
hard as that may be in these political
times
set new hampshire districts to make them
every possible one of them
as competitive as possible
yours is a sacred trust
i wish you every success in fulfilling
that trust
i will send this testimony to you
electronically as well
thank you
thank you for your testimony
next we have phil hatcher
thank you for this opportunity to
testify tonight
i am
the president of dover for the last 35
years
i'm a retired computer science professor
from unh
and i'm a member of the technical
mapping team for the open democracy map
attack
um
first i just want to mention people have
mentioned several towns already but in
fact five towns in stratford county
dover somersworth rollinsford durham and
barrington all past resolutions or
warrant articles asking for a fair and
transparent redistributing process
i hope you'll honor those resolutions
by running a process where at the end
every citizen of the state
will know why
their boundaries were drawn where they
were they may not like them
but the least understand why they were
drawn the way they were
the open boxy mapathon
project last night released
maps for congressional districts
executive council districts and the new
hampshire senate
this was done on a zoom meeting so in a
forum citizens could comment on those
maps provide input to that process
i think that's an excellent approach
my focus though on that project has been
on drawing house maps new hampshire
house maps as you get as you alluded
earlier tonight this is a very
challenging problem
uh we're
working hard on this we hope to have
house maps for the 10 counties released
on october 5th
as you alluded to there's there's very
severe challenges fulfilling
constitutional requirements
one person one vote
the requirement
in the constitution that town's a
sufficient population be given their own
dedicated rep
and requirement that districts be
contiguous
um
this could you know even the definition
of contiguous is a challenge for us i
think is meeting in a point does that
define a border the constitution talks
about a border
there's a point of border
i don't know
i'm not a lawyer but it's an open
question and i'll come back to that in a
moment it has relevance in stratfor
county
i think some people would like us to
think this is a mathematical jigsaw
puzzle
in which there's only one possible way
to put the pieces together
so for instance summers worth two dover
five and over six in 2011.
it happened because gee that's the way
it broke down it's just the only way it
could have happened
i think people want to think that they
want the rest of us to think that
so what i did as part of the map of
project is i wrote software
to automatically generate
potential
new hampshire house maps
that fulfill the constitutional
requirements and minimize
the number of towns awards
that are not given eligible towns awards
that are not given their own rep
okay this is an algorithmic
problem that is in my wheelhouse
as a former computer scientist
so
what i want to tell you is there's lots
of options in all the counties in
particular in stratford county at the
end of the day
there's literally tens or even hundreds
of different ways to configure the maps
to fulfill the constitutional
requirements
and minimize the number of towns that
are not given
eligible towns have not given their own
rep as as mandated by the constitution
so it's impossible
in general to satisfy all of them that's
what what discussion earlier was
alluding to
but i believe we should minimize that
and i think the citizens of the state
expect that from us
and just saying it's too hard to do that
is not
an adequate response
so stratfor county 2020 let me just back
up a 2010 there's actually four towns
or wards in stratford county that did
not get a dedicated rep that should have
those are milton stratford dover five
and dover six
so let's look at the stratfor county
2020 situation
you know as as you said we do not know
the war boundaries
so i again i think the public would like
to know what are you guys going to do
about that in your internal process
how are you going to deal with that what
i did in my situation i didn't know what
else to do so i took i assume the
average population reached those wards
figuring that when the towns draw the
wards they're going to have to do
something approximating that in order to
get the secretary of state to approve it
so my algorithm uses that as the input
um
other challenges in stafford county is
that there's three cities with wards
that are actually border each other
they're sort of packed together in a
corner of the county
which makes it particularly challenging
but my software tells me we can do a map
for 2020
with only two violations
if we exploit
as is exploited in the 2010 map
connecting new durham and stratford at a
point
a lot of people don't like that
so what do we do you know if the
constitution says
that every eligible town should be given
its own rep
and we can do it with two if we use that
point is that point stand up to legal
challenge
is that a border
the alternative according to my software
is you can do it with three violations
if you
don't allow
meeting at a point
also i want to
mention david andrews alternative
component method which i believe
again he's part he's actually the leader
of the technical mapping crew at the
open democracy mapathon project i
believe he presented this to you at the
merrimack listening session
my software also uses that approach as
well as the conventional component
method
and i believe using that method
we can build a map for stratfor county
with only one violation
[Music]
again i hope you'll take a close look at
that and have legal authorities take a
look at that to me it's a small tweak
to the component method that was
discussed in the supreme court decision
i'm not a lawyer however
but let me tell you with that approach
it will help in strafford county
[Music]
but now we get to the real meat which is
what are we going to do i'm claiming
and i'll be happy to share my maps with
people who are interested i'm claiming
there's tens if not hundreds of possible
ways to map stratfor county
which one are you going to choose
okay earlier tonight it sounded like you
were saying
we can't do anything that's the best we
can do that's not going to be good
enough
okay
there are trade-offs however
as i said we can get it down to two
if we allow districts to meet at a point
but a lot of people don't like that
what are we going to do
also some of my maps are going to have
large filterials which
also happened in 2011 and large can be
measured in various different ways uh
population for instance
number of precincts you know wards and
towns that are combined together or even
number of floaterial seats that you end
up with
do we not like that
um
do we want to keep city wards together
for this discussion of summers or it's
just some other be kept with somersworth
as best as we can should dover be kept
with dover should rochester be kept with
rochester is that a priority for us
and then there's the whole community of
interest idea
we have lots of choices folks we have
tens hundreds of maps to choose from
okay
are we going to use community of
interest data such as school district
boundaries to sort through those
alternatives
um
so my question is what are what are your
criteria
you know someone raised this at your
working session
um
and it was claimed it's just a
mathematical problem that's all it is
well i'm here to tell you it's not just
a mathematical problem there's lots of
solutions
you're gonna have to choose one from
those solutions
how are you going to make that choice i
think the public should know
what your criteria are
okay
[Music]
also at your working session in concord
joel anderson presented his tool
that the committee has at their
at their disposal to work on this
problem
it shocked me at that meeting that joel
actually said that
he had a database of solutions
so i'm not the only one saying there's
more than one solution
he said part of that tool is a database
of solutions
i think the public should see those
solutions
i know you say there's licensing
problems with this software i think the
public should understand i would like to
have a public statement exactly what are
those licensing problems but no matter
what the licensing process is on a
software the database of solutions
should be released to the public
for instance it helped people like me
understand how good his tool is is he
present providing you with a complete
set of possible solutions or not
moreover he has four counties he said he
hadn't been able to get to work
i've got solutions for stratfor county
he didn't have it maybe he's fixed his
tool now maybe it's working i don't
know what what does his tool do about
ward boundaries
how are you using that tool he has to
have made some assumption about war
bodies
i think it'd be good for the public to
know what that is as well if you are
truly using his tool
so let me just close there my point is
that there are a lot of solutions
for mapping counties for new hampshire
house maps
you need criteria to sort through the
possibilities you should discuss that in
a public session so we can see what
you're thinking is and you should
publicize what those criteria are
again i'd be happy to share anything
that i have there's no licensing
agreements on my software i'm happy to
share whatever you want to see with it
the only data it takes as input is the
same as joel's it takes populations and
it takes the
you know which districts are adjacent to
which districts
thank you very much
thank you phil
jack gail is next
thank you senators and representatives
this opportunity jack gale from
barrington
um
only three years in barrington
transplant from south of the border
like many might be
since i can't tell you a lot of stories
about stratford county i'll share a
cautionary tale from the south of the
border
it's not going to be about
elbridge gary you all know where that
term came from and what he did in the
18th century
this is about carol cleven
a representative of a town of chemsword
mass just south of the border
37 000 people we had our own rap
intersection of two
federal highways
well-off good school system all the
things that communities aspire for
and for the longest time they had their
representative on beacon hill
in the last round of redistricting
which was a closed and very political
process there that
probably
only could have happened there in
massachusetts but uh
they decided to break up the wards
and the citizens of chemsford where i
lived had to go to four different places
and we had four different reps all from
other towns
nobody from those districts could run
because you were only a small portion
towns one quarter of our size had
representatives
and a precinct from our town
it upset a lot of citizens in our town
and it wasn't the only location where it
happened
um despite what's on my shirt
uh i voted for carol she was rep a good
rep
attentive listened to her community
she was a republican in massachusetts a
rare bird
um
and of course she lost her seat
concerned citizens decided to look into
the process they got it opened up with
freedom of information laws and stuff
and they
found under the rock
some very ugly things that happened
i'm not accusing this on this committee
at all
but concerned citizens who really didn't
understand this process
opened it
up and it did not go well for some of
the people involved
i would recommend a website
google and you could look at the end of
the career
of thomas finneran in massachusetts
a very powerful man on beacon hill
it got ugly for him
and he lost his position
over the political decisions made in
redistricting in 2010.
it's not going to happen here
if you measure up to the ideals that
you've set forth in the process
and do what the citizens behind me ask
for
it shouldn't be a problem
but
if 60 or more than 60 cases were brought
after november with no evidence
i hate to think what would happen
if the citizens decided that this wasn't
done fairly
i wish you success
and hope you can honor the ideals of
this process that you have before you
thank you
thank you mr scale
matt
gerding is there a matt gerding gerding
okay no matt garretting let's go uh next
representative schmidt
welcome
[Music]
good evening colleagues
since i may not be around 10 years from
now
to weigh in uh feel obligated to
add a couple of views with regard to the
citiz the citizens of dober and
somersworth you've already heard some of
this and the acoustics being what they
are i'm not sure that i heard any of it
accurately but
some of the people seem to make
quite a bit of sense
that i could hear
but
the situation in dover and somersworth
is one that i hope will not be
maintained or repeated and i joined the
suit uh 10 years ago
to try to change that because
what was done was not proper
um
[Music]
i talked with the secretary of state
about 10 years ago and showed him the
numbers
that the water realignment in dover had
produced uh as you know the the supreme
court has not said that every entity has
to be exactly equal to every other one
in terms of population you just have to
get as close as is workable and
practical
and the the secretary of state mr
gardner said at that time that the
result that the ward realignment process
in dover had produced was perfect to use
his words because a dover has a
population that breaks down in its six
wards to about
5 000
per ward
and that's what they had
each ward had just a few more if you're
less than five thousand
um
and
therefore under the constitution
every one of those awards was entitled
to a representative of its own
and taken two wards together
to have a floatario
i represent wards one and two
and have for the past 19 years wards one
and two
five thousand per ward
roughly
uh
taken together is ten thousand so under
the constitution that would be
approximate that would be three reps for
awards one and two and that's what
that's what wards one and two got
and wards three and four are very very
similar numbers
um and they're entitled also to three
reps
that's what they got
words five and six you've heard referred
to already several times
um
five and six had essentially the same
population as all the other awards in
dover um and therefore they were
entitled to three reps
but specifically ward five was entitled
to one rep of its own
and one floatarial rep right word six
was entitled to one rep of its own and
one floatarial
rep
um
and that's not what five and six got
they got
put together with summers worth two
um and
the three reps that wound up getting
elected from that district i believe
it's trafford 17.
[Music]
they
they got elected
at large
that's not what the constitution calls
for that's one of the reasons i joined
the suit that's not what the
constitution calls for it calls for one
from five
one from six and one from five and six
together
but instead
they got this
lumping together with summer's worth two
now if you look at
uh summers were two and five and wards
five and six in dover together
from eagle eye view they six and and
ward two uh
lie next to each other but they don't
have any uh any real contact because
there's a there's will and pond and and
the forest and so forth and so on it's
not like some of the ward lines in dover
where ward x is on one side of the
street and the ward y
starts right on the other side of the
street they have a their that's a
neighborhood they have a real connection
but
i protested against that situation
because in addition
to the
inequity that's that i've already spoken
to
you have a situation where given
the the workings of the election you
might have all three representatives be
from dover
or all three of them could be from ward
two and somersworth
and in the first time and i think the
second term under that regime
you had all three representatives from
dover
therefore summer's worth two
representatives had no representation
whatsoever
that they were
technically uh entitled to
that's unfair that's wrong
i don't want to see that happen again
and you folks have some authority to put
something together that
that ends that situation that's unfair
and
now in the last couple of years uh we've
had one of the representatives from
from district 17 b from ward 2 and
somersworth
but he's his loyalties if you will are
kind of divided too because he doesn't
just represent
ward two and somersworth he represents
five and six in dover as well what does
he know about five and six in dover it
doesn't live there there's no natural
uh you know interaction of the
populations and so forth
now the the ward realignment in in dover
as it was done 10 years ago was very
conscientious i wasn't on that ward
realignment board so i'm not patting
myself one to the back to say it was
done extremely conscientiously and
competently
um and that's the the and the result was
so close to 5 000 in each one of the
awards that as i say
secretary of state gardner on looking at
it he said oh that's perfect
of course perfection is not required it
was a characterization not a
mathematical assessment
but
it didn't work out for wards five and
six and some is worth two
and it shouldn't be done again
of course i also have some objections to
the to the
districting that was done with regard to
the executive council that was clearly a
gerrymandering never should it be done
that way and it shouldn't be permitted
to continue
look at that
district that the dover is in
and it's connected by one
town
in the middle
[Music]
you can do better than that and i hope
you will
so
uh i i think there was a question with
regard to the dover situation
from representative smith earlier on and
if she has not been enlightened by what
i've had to say would be happy to try to
answer a question or from representative
turcotte
but otherwise thank you very much for
your attention i certainly hope the
microphone works well enough in terms of
the recording so that i can listen to
everybody else's remarks and figure out
what the heck they actually did say
thank you just for information when i'm
on my phone i'm trying to text to see
how things are going i am informed the
live stream is coming through loud and
clear
um so i expect that anything that goes
online you'll be able to hear quite well
right and we're trying to stay on top of
that right and and one other thing for
the edification of all of you i sit in
front of one of these microphones in the
gel car as does uh senator gray on a
regular basis
and you have to get right up so that
the fact that you're taking the bite out
of it because when you were speaking
before madam chair and you were up here
and the mic was down here
i could hear you talking i just couldn't
understand whether it was english or
some other language
when you speak up like that we can all
hear you but but mike don't help
thank you representative schmidt uh rep
representative janet wall
then we will move on to representative
timothy horrigan
so i am representative timothy horrigan
from stratfor county district six which
is the towns of
durham and madbury or as i like to call
it greater madbury um we're
one of the uh we're one of the districts
that claim closest that came we were
like almost exactly the exact um
population for for five reps and
actually it looks like um judging by the
numbers i got from the census bureau
website
will be pretty close to a fraction
percentage point for next time although
my first two terms we were put in with
lee that was because we have a community
of interest um were part of the same
uh
the three towns of durham lee and
madbury are part of the same same
district and you absolutely are allowed
to
take communities of interest such as
school districts into account it's not
just about the numbers which um
brings me to uh
basically my uh
my first point is um there's gonna be a
lot we're gonna you're gonna make a
decision about what a reasonable
deviation from the uh
from the ideal number is because the
audio number is
3448 and the towns and the city wards in
the state
have numbers all over the place they
they're not all exact multiples of
3448 so that makes your life a little
tougher um
the constitution there's a
constitutional amendment which was
passed in 2006 it's never really been
obeyed
which
says in addition to districts having to
be
contiguous um
each each town each city ward is
entitled to its own own member
um within and says something about a
reasonable with an um if reasonably
practicable so it is reasonably
practicable
but we will probably have to use a
larger deviation than the plus or minus
five percent you know that's uh
been representative committee i heard
that when i viewed the youtube of the
district of the uh
of the original organizational center
that's not necessarily true we can have
a higher deviation just means we have to
finish the plan
quicker if we have to send it to federal
court it'll have to go to federal court
um even the even the state house the
state senate districts are within the
purview of the federal government
and but they probably
would approve a plan with a higher
deviation especially since uh we our
state constitution pretty clearly states
that if a town that we should maximize
the number of towns that have their own
rep it's not just a question of
maximizing the number of districts as
was said 10 years ago by the then
majority leader it's uh you need to
maximize the number of towns that have
their own have their own rep and
[Music]
i didn't bring them with me i won't bore
you with it i did actually make up a
plan
i didn't have a mapping program i just
did it on a spreadsheet that uh
did a pretty good job of of uh obeying
that but
there was uh
when you get to the northern corner of
the state uh its
another corner of the county i mean it
is pretty hard to keep it within plus or
minus five percent um so the district i
came up with was the three town new
durham middleton and uh milton and i
think it was 13 off everybody else was
like
within zero and six percent off um i
won't i've said too much about that but
you absolutely can use a bigger
definition vermont has about the same
ratio of uh
residents to state reps and they
the plan they used for the last 10 years
was uh
i think
it varied from uh some districts or 10
percent off their ideals others were up
to 10 so it's like a plus or minus 10
percent or a 20 and their plan passed
constitutional muster so they get the
feds did not overturn their plans so we
can
and they have more flexibility because
you can divide um municipalities in two
and you can find them into two pieces in
vermont whereas we have to you know
we can't draw
um we can't draw lines across uh
municipal uh city town or ward
boundaries and i also think it'd be good
idea even though it's not required in
the law
not to draw too many districts across
city lines trying to just certainly what
was revenant schmidt
mentioned where they
stuck dover and part of dover and part
of summersworth did make the numbers
work better but i think that was not a
good idea i don't i mean the members who
were elected of all
serve both cities and the town of
rollins for uh with distinction but it
would have been better
not to have a district that was
partially dover and partially summer's
worth that's just uh in my mind
made no sense
and
another issue
contiguity we mentioned the so-called
merski bow tie district which was paul
merski the representative griffin's
predecessor 10 years ago is famous for
his collection of bow ties um
where those two towns met
at a point deep in the woods you had to
drive about 20 miles to get from one
town to the other
i
understood i understood just fiddling
around even with my printed map and
spreadsheet i now understood why he did
it
in terms of the numbers but that's
you don't have to do that to get an
acceptable plan um you can put stratford
in with another community i actually
i did you could even put it in for
example with uh with rochester because
um
so you don't there are other things you
can do with stratford other than
sticking it with new durham there's a
couple there's like at least one other
blatantly non-contiguous district in the
state in belknap county whose meeting
hasn't happened yet but there's a
district that's guilford and
meredith where they meet out in the
middle of meredith bay
you have to drive about through three
miles of laconia to get from uh guilford
to meredith um
i remember like the chair at the time
said well it's just a short drive across
the weirs which is true but that was not
a contiguous district it's not been
drawn that way when
and actually even representative perkins
focus sentence district is only
contiguous in the loosest sense of the
lord since uh portsmouth is separated
from the rest of her district by uh by
little bay i mean there is a
bridge which has been renovated in the
past 10 years so there is like a very i
mean it's not hard to get not hard to
drive or even walk or bicycle from
uh
from from dover to portsmouth or from
durham to portsmouth but her district is
technically it's
contiguous in a fairly loose sense of
the words so um
my other talking point the software we
haven't heard much about the software
apparently
um some sort of software either
will be acquired by the committee or is
being acquired
what i heard
just listening on youtube at one of the
previous meetings i got what seemed like
a very very vague answer when they went
on about how difficult it was now
there's licensing issues i interpreted
that to me no you're not planning to
distribute it but that's
a decision that could be changed there
are in fact
eventually open democracy mapathon
they're using there are they're using
just one of many you know open source
public domain
mapping softwares that are out there so
you could easily
put together an open source
um software package to uh
that
you know respects the ward and city and
town lines and allows for floatarials
um it's actually the actual drawing the
plan it's a very politically it's a very
complicated issue it's a good thing
you're having all these hearings but
actually the actual nuts and bolts of
drawing the plan probably are not as
hard as you think um
eight years ago
eight years ago i actually drew up my
own plan because the software contractor
for that time was eventually released to
the public so i still had it two years
after the fact and i definitely only
like a couple of days of work um to
put together a
put together a plan which was you know
probably not as
i mean it was just obviously i thought
it was fine not that everybody would
think about it actually actually once
you actually
sit down and decide how to draw the plan
it's not actually going to take you that
long to do it it's not quite as
complicated as
you're probably going to represent it as
being but that's fine and
finally my last point and i've made too
many i've made a lot of points already
is please please please get the plan out
in time first of all get it out in time
if you take my advice and go with the
larger deviation please put on enough
time for the fed for the state and
federal courts to actually uh review the
plan because they're undoubtedly no
matter what you do there will be
lawsuits
and um so put in town also put enough
time so people who are thinking running
office know where their district is
going to be like last year
i mean i was i was in durham and mad
very so i wasn't the only thing i had to
worry about was whether or not uh lee
was in my district but there's a number
of there's lots of people there who are
thinking and running even for house
seats who don't know where the district
is going to be especially if you
thinking running for the executive
council
or the uh or even uh for you know the
state senate u.s congress you it's
lots of people inches those offices and
they're totally at a loss to figure out
like where exactly we're going to draw
the lines so if you draw the lines a
little bit sooner than we did 10 years
ago that would i think be a really nice
thing for you to do for everyone
involved and
so uh
so good luck good luck with it it's a i
know this is a very complicated job and
no one's going to be pleased with the
result no matter what although it wasn't
that terrible last time in fact
and chair was actually the house side is
very fair-minded he carefully drew
himself a district
and he was a conservative republican
that was immediately immediately lost in
20 in 2012 to a liberal democrat on foot
so um thanks a lot for your time and uh
good luck with this whole process
thank you representative
uh is it james feischer fisher
it's james fisher
funny spelling but it's still fisher
uh i'm not running for office i'm not a
representative i'm not planning on being
a representative running for office i'm
just a normal citizen
i'm also a retired physician
and uh i happen to live in dover ward
five
uh and the i pay both dover taxes and in
the back my property i pay madbury taxes
because
that part is in madbury
um and so to discover that i share
a congr a district with somersworth on
the other side of dover is kind of a
shock to me
and i'm really not sure how
one representative
could
fairly
represent
somersworth and
my part of dover at the same time it
seems
well it's kind of like
it's kind of like buying fish
you know does it pass the smell test
and this just doesn't pass the smell
test
so
it
and i think that's my concern tonight
and that's probably the message i want
to to bring out to you
is that whatever you do and and listen
i'm no expert in redistricting i'm no
expert in
in politics
i really don't care about that i think
most patients or most patients yeah most
people don't don't care about you i've
been practicing for a long time
uh
most people don't care about that either
they they're kind of like me they want
to see if it if it passes the smell test
and so i have
three asks of this committee
i'm not going to tell you how to do your
job although
why you wouldn't want to pass this off
to some independent group so they take
the heat i don't know but that's that's
that's up to you not me
um my first ask is that
at the end of the day when you finish
the the process
does do the districts that you've drawn
does that accurately reflect
the geography the politics of the state
if the state is evenly divided into
democrats and republicans and
independents
do the maps reflect that or do they
reflect a bias towards one group or the
other
and
that's important because of my second
ask
we've seen in the
certainly this year we've seen an
insurrection
at the capitol
in an attempt to overthrow an election
we've seen
our
national congress unable to come up with
decisions to to get the country out of
debt
to to move forward in some of the
projects that we need to move forward on
to become competitive in the world
and worse we've seen neighbors
fighting against each other
because our representatives
have secure seats
they have a sure thing
they don't have to answer to all their
constituents they only have to answer to
the constituents that
they want to answer to that they've
selected
when they've decided who their what
their district is going to look like
and
therefore the idea of compromise the
idea of working out solutions is no
longer something that we're interested
in this country we're only interested in
satisfying our own constituents
so
one of the reasons i moved to new
hampshire well over 35 years ago is
because this is a state that values
representation this is a state where
neighbors actually take care of each
other
i
i have respect for each and every one of
you i think you're all here not i mean
some of you i mean you have to mind your
own party i understand all of that okay
i can i can deal with that
but
you also really care about this state
and you really care about your neighbors
and
the only way that i can see as a
physician as as a as a citizen of the
state that we can come together
as a nation but certainly come together
as a state
is if we have
districts where people actually have to
talk to each other have to work things
out so that
one group doesn't dominate over all the
rest we may not agree on anything but
we've got to be able to agree to
disagree and we're not even able to do
that
and and gerrymandering isn't the whole
problem but it's part of the problem and
it's a problem that you actually have a
chance to fix
that you can actually do something about
you can send a message to
every citizen in this state at the end
of the day when you've drawn up your
maps when you've done what you think is
the right thing to do
and and it has to pass the smell test
and
and you can say to every member of this
state we care about you your voice is
important to us but we also want you to
talk to each other to talk to your
neighbors and value your neighbors
because that's what new hampshire is
about
and
and to draw district lines to
separate people to divide the nation is
only going to make the problem worse
so my second ask is
please well i guess it's the first task
too and how they think about it you know
pass the smell test at the end of the
day
my last ask is that you give us time to
review what you've done at the end of
the day not just 24 hours but let us
look at it i mean
the people that have come before me have
already said you know they want they
want the ability to say you know to be
able to be looked in the eye and said
this is why we drew it the way we did
and we tried to be as fair as we could
i trust you uh i have to trust you
you're our representatives but i also
want to thank you for all the work that
you've done some of you've come a long
distance to be here and i appreciate
that
and
i wish you luck and i thank you for the
opportunity to talk
thank you
representative peter bixby
good evening
for the record i'm representing peter
bixby representing stratfor district 17
which uh represents two wards in dover
and one ward in somersworth
and um i'd just like to uh
make a quick reference to our part two
article 11 of the constitution
uh when a population of any town or ward
according to the last federal census is
in
is within a reasonable deviation from
the ideal population for one or more
representative seats
the town or ward shall have its own
district of one or more representative
seats and skipping out
down a little bit
informing districts the boundaries of
towns wards and unincorporated places
shall be preserved and contiguous
so um
i like summersworth
but i don't think it's fair that i am
representing people as a
as a resident of dover
i am representing
the people of ward 2 and somersworth i
think that they should have
a
dedicated they should
uh have a dedicated representative that
covers their ward and probably one other
award in order to balance it out in
summer's worth uh as opposed to being
tacked on to dover uh
it so happens that there is one
representative from ward 2 and in
summer's worth at this point but
typically anybody who is running from
somersworth is going to be a
disadvantage against anyone who is
running against the two wards in in
dover uh so uh it is set up to uh
essentially uh not represent that ward
in summer's worth and i i don't think
that's appropriate
um
so
uh and this is
this is one instance of this that
happened in the last redistricting there
were a number of others
uh i think hudson and pelham probably
have even more to complain about than
than summer's worth in this case because
uh hud pelham is smaller than hudson and
has
basically
gets hubs hudson representatives because
of that
uh so
um
so
i i really would urge you to pay close
attention to that idea of making sure
that any
uh ward or town or district that is
large enough for its own representative
gets one
and
uh
pay
also pay attention to
the uh requirement that
uh
boundaries of towns and rewards be
respected
and i recognize that that you with the
way numbers work out it's not going to
be perfect and that's why we have
floatarial districts which can help do
that further balancing
um
and so uh
that
that's the main thing i'm here for i
would also like to urge as a number of
people have also done before that uh
when there is a draft
that map be published soon enough so
that there's a chance for public
hearings and public comment and that
public those public hearings should also
be made accessible to remote access
uh so
with that i'll close and uh i wish you
good luck uh with this fairly
complicated process thank you
thank you representative bixby for those
in the audience and around the table we
are on a pace to finish right around
eight we have five more individuals who
are what's that
oh
all right well i have five more on my
sheet and a couple more after that i
guess uh next is emmett saldatti
thank you representatives thank you
senators my name is emmett stoldatti i
hail from somersworth
which is the smallest the tiniest city
in the state of new hampshire it is so
small that it probably should be a town
and it actually was a town for much of
its history
except back in the 1800s the great falls
manufacturing company a textile mill
company that built the mills decided
that the townsfolk were not doing enough
to serve the corporate interests of the
great falls manufacturing company and
the ceo of the great falls manufacturing
company came up with a brilliant idea in
1890 and that was to turn somersworth
then great falls into a city
and by turning it into a city they could
split it into five wards
and fortunately for them uh many of the
folks in the wards did not speak english
most of them spoke uh french because
they were
french-canadian
and they were able to identify enough
people in these five wards that were
sympathetic to the corporate interests
of the great falls manufacturing company
and they were successful in 1893
somersworth then great falls became a
city and they elected five
representatives against the four
at-large representatives that were very
sympathetic to the corporate interests
of somersworth
which is the nature of my remarks today
is that i think as much as the folks
before me have spoken about uh making
sure that our electorate
and the the citizenry that elects them
feels confident uh in the political
makeup
of our maps i'm also concerned about the
economic representation in our state
you've heard a lot about executive
council district two i had the good
fortune of running as a candidate in
executive council district two
and representative weber has probably
heard enough people from stafford county
mispronounce westmoreland
and that's an apt
way of thinking about why we should draw
maps that represent our communities
where we actually know the names of the
towns and the people that are there
because if you don't have connections
with a community or region
then how are you expected to represent
the people there
and how are you expected to get elected
in those regions with no connections
unless you have financial resources to
do so
and so by drawing fair maps
what we are actually doing is tipping
the balance of favor against financial
resources into community resources
so that folks who have access to their
community have relationships with their
community whether it's by being active
in their local church community being
active with local nonprofits or food
pantries or being a business owner that
has served their community
those are the kinds of social capital
that can allow people to run for office
in regions when they otherwise might not
have deep pockets or backed by special
interest groups and so i asked the
committee today to consider that fair
maps not only means
that these districts are being
represented
by a good spread of the values and
political ideologies
but also allow people to run for office
and get elected to represent their
communities based on those connections
and not just based on their pockets or
their ability to send a lot of glossy
mailers across the state even though
they can't even pronounce the cities and
towns with which they represent
i would echo the sentiment of many folks
before me that we have opportunities as
them as members of the public to review
these maps to identify indeed if we
think they represent the communities of
our sau districts of our public health
regions of our business communities uh
and other types of regions with which we
associate and in closing a neighbor of
mine jules good could not be here today
and i just wanted to read her remarks
sorry if this is sort of double hitting
this is from jules good a neighbor of
mine in somersworth some of the people
who will be most impacted by
redistricting do not have an opportunity
to share their perspectives tonight
which not only limits government
transparency but also stifles important
discourse people who do not have
transportation access people who cannot
physically access this space and people
who work outside of regular office hours
are disenfranchised when we eliminate a
remote testimony and attendance option
in order for the redistricting process
to be truly fair and transparent these
listening sessions must have a remote
participation option jules good summers
with resident and disability rights
activist thank you members of the
committee
thank you for your testimony isaac
epstein
no isaac
okay we'll move on to parker cook
of dover
hi everybody
my name is parker cook and i live here
in dover and i represent myself um i'm
not involved in a political organization
or
i think one thing i've learned from
sitting here is that in a city of 33 000
people this room can of roughly 45
people is all we have here
and i don't think it's because we don't
care as a city or as a community
um i think it's because after we count
our votes
you know we we have jobs we have
families we have
a busy life and we put our faith in you
folks that when we're not looking
you folks have our best interests in
mind
um that not only
we don't believe that we'll agree with
you folks all the time but
we hope that your faith
and your loyalty above all else is to a
just
and durable democracy
and
i find my faith a little bit shaken when
i look at i know it's been talked about
already um but the executive council
district map
tomorrow morning during breakfast
i'm going to show my five-year-old
daughter a picture of that map and i'm
going to ask her which one doesn't look
like the rest and i think everybody here
knows which one she's going to point to
without putting down her her toast
and so all i really want to say is that
at the end of this
process
um
i just
i just want you folks to be able to say
to yourselves that
yes above all else above my above my
party or any other interest
i've contributed to our democracy
thank you so much
thank you parker for your testimony next
representative welper
uh thank you for the record my name is
representative kurt welper i represent
stratfor district three the towns of
stratford
new durham one of those infamous
districts that is connected by a point
i have to represent both towns here so
i'm going to do that in very short order
stratford
has a population 39.91 according to your
map and is equi has enough reps enough
population to warrant its own rep and we
want one
currently we have two shared with new
durham
new durham does not have enough
population for a rep
and so they have to be married to
somebody else
and they really might be married to
stratford
because
stratford and new durham are such
similar towns they have a similar
economy similar geography
and they operate quite differently but
it makes a great district problems in
one town are problems than the other
everybody understands each other it
works out great
and i
wish you
god's grace as you go forward
thank you representative welfare
nancy pierpont
i am nancy pierpont i have resided in
madbury since march of 1993.
um
i'm coming here to um
say that we want everyone to have a
voice
mad berry
has a population of 1918
people
um
we share a school district with durham
and lee
and we are so small that our
representatives are combined as uh
representative tim explained with with
durham
but that doesn't mean that we're not
important in fact we are the keepers of
the water supply
for
portsmouth and dover
and so i'm just asking you to make sure
that despite our small size and madberry
that
our voices count equally
to other people
in addition to that point i would like
to talk about my work that i do
as a result of being a member of the
madbury united church of christ
we made a decision about 20 years ago to
share our building with the maranatha
indonesian indonesian united church of
christ which was at that time a
fellowship it joined our denomination as
a result of our
sister
hood in the church
that brought me to also chair the new
hampshire conference united church of
christ immigrant and refugee support
group
um
and in that work we have seen many
immigrants
go through the asylum process
and gain citizenship
and so as you are going through this
process i would like you to think about
as i think uh emmett seldotti also uh
said
the
spectrum of the populace
um to make sure that we are hearing
the voices of new americans
uh we're often saying to ourselves oh we
need some new blood around here some new
new voices well
hear them
make sure they count
uh we uh
like to think of ourselves as just white
here in new hampshire and that's not the
case anymore
so
open your eyes and make sure please that
you include everyone's voice
the small towns the new americans
anyone who's not you in your
stereotypical
new hampshire idea
include them
thank you
thank you nancy next uh former
representative dave dave bickford
david bickford
thank you very much i was worried about
ever getting here
but uh
anyway i'm
from district 3
and
it doesn't really work out very well
because
we may be connected by a point as kurt
walpole just told you
however i when i was a state rep for
that area
i had to drive through three other towns
before i could get there it takes me
almost as
much time to get to my next district as
it did to get to concord from where i
live
um
so we don't really know what the other
town's doing it's like emmett solati
just
told us um we're just not we're just not
connected
even though there's a point that
connects us we just don't go that way
it's just class six row that connects
out that way and nobody uses it the
bridge is out
um
so if you could
in your deliberations uh consider the uh
transportation corridors to get us there
i was a state representative for 16
years and when i first started back in
i think it was 96 that sound right marge
thank you
um
i was coupled with middleton and that
worked out pretty good they're about
seven miles away
um and then we had the multiple
districts and that was very difficult
and probably worse than what we have
now
i think i'd rather stick with stratfor
than go back to that
so and that's really all i ask is to try
and uh take that into consideration when
you can't i understand the difficulty of
the job
and that's all i want to tell you i've
been waiting 10 years to tell you that
thank you
and i believe this is our final speaker
heath howard
hello thank you for having me
uh my name is heath howard i live in
stratford uh and i ran for state
representative in stratford-03 the towns
of stratfor and new durham
as you had just previously heard from
some of the previous people uh
stratfor and new durham are not
necessarily connected
in the most contiguous way
of course when looking at the economics
behind uh
the connection between stratford and new
durham there's far less
connection than between new durham and
farmington as route 11 is often seen as
the lifeblood
of that town where a lot of businesses
set up around it as well as king's
highway a little bit further north is
another population center in new durham
which goes and connects through uh
middleton
it takes me 40 minutes to drive up to
new durham whenever i leave and i'm
going out uh
trying to get there
and i have to drive through belknap
county
when that same trip as previously stated
it would take me to conquer
stratford has the population to have its
own state representative yet it doesn't
and we're linking it with new durham
simply because
new durham
is culturally similar
yet when looking at everything
comparatively
uh
new durham is far more similar to
farmington middleton
and milton
than it is to stratford and it makes far
more sense to put them together based
off
geographic location
uh
as well as the fact that they do not
share a public school uh any
uh public safety resources
uh
community services such as uh religious
services
so and uh youth sports
so it makes no sense why they should be
in a district together and why new
durham shouldn't be
put with another town and stratford be
left on its own
thank you
is there anybody else who did not sign
up that wishes to speak
yes sir
come on up
you may
um i first wanted to talk a little bit
about stuff before we begin just state
your name and where your front place uh
david andrews i'm a volunteer with
the open democracy mapathon group um and
since we are in the uh tip of the dragon
i figured i would talk about the
executive council
map
um as you can see uh district two
which many have talked about is
clearly um
gerrymandered
[Music]
what we have displayed here is the
number so the red arrows
display the
high school saus that are broken up by
this
map the green arrows are where uh county
lines are crossed
so you can see i believe there's 19 high
school saus that are broken up by this
one
district
and um
as high school as they use our community
of interest um i believe that we should
try to keep them together uh at all
costs um so as a
organization and uh reaching out to the
community
we went through a uh mapping process
that uh actually concluded last night
for the congressional the executive
council and the senate maps um so what
we did was we
went out uh
and tried to find the
most important communities of interest
to the people of new hampshire uh and
what they what we found was that uh
school districts were very important to
people shared emergency services so
shared police shared ems shared fire
departments were very important um
proximity to hospitals was very
important
and then uh
issues like uh pfas and um poverty
drug use that kind of thing so we use
those to um
kind of define our communities of
interests
we then
created criteria for each of our maps um
so
following the constitution first so we
population deviation needs to be
low um everything needs to be contiguous
and
uh
and town ward lines should not be broken
up uh we then added our own uh criteria
based on input from uh
people in the the group um so we wanted
to preserve communities of interest
for uh executive council we wanted
compact districts
and we wanted to preserve uh county
lines as much as possible
and so what we came up with um using
those criteria was this map uh well we
came up with a number of different maps
that were voted on by a
group of citizens and they came to the
conclusion that this was the the map
of the maps that were presented that
they liked the best and what you can see
is that only three high school saus are
broken up uh the districts are a lot
more compact
and they make regional sense so you can
see there's a northern district uh
southern district the central district
the seacoast district and a western uh
district um
and you can you can just between these
two maps you can really tell
um
one is fair and one is not um that's not
always the case you can draw maps that
are very gerrymandered that look like
they're not gerrymandered and it's very
important that you look behind the the
curtain and make sure that even though
it may i know a lot of people have said
that it needs to pass the smell test
you can't uh conduct a smell test by
simply looking at a map you can come up
with a number of different maps that are
gerrymandered that don't look
gerrymandered i've accidentally done it
myself um so what i would do is i
when i was doing my mapping i wouldn't
really look at um partisan voting but at
the end i would make sure that i didn't
accidentally gerrymander and create uh
pac districts of either democrats or
republicans so this uh map here
currently is
a very uh fair map in partisan uh
in a partisan way there's uh
a couple lean districts and the the
uh
one district is very very fair which
will swing either way on any given
election which is which is what we want
we want the people to decide who their
electors are um
and uh
yeah so i think that's all i wanted to
say and uh thank you for your time
uh copies of all the maps that we've
done at the next um
county hearing we're working on the
preparation of those and they will
include
the charts that compare these
oh sorry i'm brian beale deputy director
of open democracy and uh the
organizer of the mapathon project
we will have charts and graphs for you
thank you representative turcotte for
conducting the hearing i want to thank
everybody here for coming and speaking i
want to thank um
the last presenters here for the maps i
was online checking i am told that the
site is live to upload maps at least
today so that can
start
um also be aware again that the links to
the redistricting for the house and
senate are on
the general court apparently home page
and the house and senate pages
also you can submit testimony online
through those websites
so you can do that and as you've heard
tonight from our last uh
witnesses testifying there are free
programs out there for
um
doing districting i know there's
district builder and a number of them
the census data is available online i
want to thank people tonight for some of
the specific information that they gave
us
and
i think with that we are done from the
house senator gray did the senate want
to add anything
excuse me normally the senate doesn't
allow
you know charts and stuff to be brought
into the hearing rooms we prefer
that you give the handouts to the
individuals i didn't say anything about
it tonight because i'm sure that that
you people didn't understand that
the senate website is up the senate
email address
is up for accepting all of that and if
it is provided through those email
addresses
and stuff it will be posted on the
website so that everyone will be able to
see it but again
you know a lot of times when you put
those charts up you block the view of
the people behind you so they can't see
it and they can't see why you're
presenting that so
it is that is part of the reason why we
prefer the handouts
to
you know charts and stuff that you you
would bring forward and with that i'll
close the senate part of this hearing
thank you everybody for coming um
senator senator gray did you want to
recognize
oh senator perkins coco i did i just had
a procedural clarification if i could uh
chairwoman griffin you mentioned that
if folks did want to continue to make
the comment to have zoom input to these
meetings that that was properly directed
to the speaker so could we expect that
we would receive a response from the
speaker if the response is no
um
as as
may have been pointed out and i'm sure
you were aware in the senate hearings
there were some
substantial issues we found with zoom
testimony and it is not practical at
this time to be going forward
additionally we have counties that do
not have
access the way we do in the southern
tier
so the decision at this point is no if
the speaker's office issues something
differently i will let people know they
are aware that there are outstanding
requests
um and
that is the situation at this point in
time so thank you very much thank you
i'm glad we could clarify that i would
think for the last time in regards to
these hearings if something changes i
will certainly let everybody know and um
house members i have a piece of paper
for you you might want for mileage
before you go
good night everybody thank you for
coming